well good day to you folks time to start
our first our third session and the way
we'll do that i'll try to try to is the
operative world summarize a bit what was
going on in the previous two sessions
and introduce the material for the the
present session and then we have with us
a guest noted sociologist of religion
David Martin from London School of
Economics and we're delighted that you
can be with us and after my remarks
Professor Martin is going to make his
remarks and then we'll be followed by 25
minutes of discussion take a break and
then reconvene to continue our
discussion so it's a kind of standard
format that we will follow in this case
as in previous ones as well so now last
week we talked about the stakes in
getting the faith and globalization
right and we talked about the questions
of relationship between the faiths and
how they relate to one another to to
each other as kind of sites of communal
identity a bit of reflection whether
they're able to form more flexible
identity that can engage others remember
the phrase open versus closed that Tony
Blair has consistently used and let me
talk about relationship between faiths
not so much among themselves but in
relationship to globalization how are
they fates related to globalization
processes and in what ways might they
contribute to humanizing globalization
we talked about this idea of pursuing
flat meanings of decreasing pain and
increasing pleasure through consumerism
as one kind of default feature of
globalization processes versus achieving
to striving to achieve human flourishing
within a
compelling vision overarching
interpretation of reality so
relationship among faiths and then
relation of faiths to globalization
processes assumptions that we operated
with is that fates are able to form
distinct but flexible identities and
foster reconciliation that's a major
assumption whether that's correct or not
remains to be seen the other assumption
was globalization processes do not
contain in and of themselves a
compelling vision of human flourishing
that too may be a contested assumption
and globalization processes may need to
be supplied by cultural capital that
comes from religious sources or from
other overarching interpretation of life
some open issues that we have touched
upon and that have generated discussions
and that remain as open issues and I
think that we have to attend to as the
course unfolds one issue was this can
exclusive his face foster reconciliation
do not exclusivist religious commitments
and yeah sarah has mentioned a
particular case of salvation only
through Jesus Christ other religions
have similar kinds of claims can such
exclusivist religious claims be combined
with social tolerance and default
physician seems to me seems to be that
religious exclusivism leads to social
exclusivism but is that sustained by
data that'll be interesting to explore
and if it is is that an inherent
position or is that something that it's
acquired of religion by religions in a
certain particular setting another issue
that I think Tony Blair has raised was
can be distinguished between faith as a
mere cultural resource the resource and
faith I think he used the word
spirituality and maybe you can describe
it as a kind of deep commitment even
commitment to our faith tradition
and surmise that in the case when faith
functions merely as cultural resource it
may undermine reconciliation and indeed
foster some conflict or deepen conflict
and in the second case when it's a
matter of deep spiritual commitment that
it may contain resources for overcoming
conflicts so those are some of the open
issues and then open issue was due
globalization processes contain values
and in particular values that align
themselves well with human flourishing I
think that's also an issue that ought to
be on the table as we go along do
globalization processes fourth issue
left on their own create competition for
scarce resources while then they
themselves have no ways to adjudicating
or provide means to adjudicating these
conflicts that's one of the issues that
Tony Blair has raised do we need faiths
do we need other overarching
interpretations of reality to provide
framework for adjudicating those
conflicts that are caused by the
competition for scarce resources so
that's roughly I think what we talked
about and that's roughly the issues that
remain open let me just now briefly
summarize where we might be in the
session today the stakes are high in
getting the issue of faith and
globalization right that's again the
assumption because faiths are
significant even if they're an
ambivalent force in the world today and
the veins are ambivalent in their
concrete effects they have again
assumption or or our hypothesis they
have a potential for doing immense good
in the world two things we mentions I
said foster and reconciliation and
humanizing globalization processes now
these are preliminary conclusions and or
preliminary hypotheses to find out
whether they're valid I think one of the
things we need to do is just find bit
more out about what's going on
concretely on the ground
and in the world of faiths and that's
partly what we're trying to do now in
this session so helicopter is coming a
bit more down now this is a huge
stratospheric view that we had before
laden with all sorts of assumptions
we're coming closer to the ground to
engage a bit of a descriptive even even
work and see what's going on in the
world of faith I know that for some of
you that's nil not quite close enough to
the ground because you're interested in
policy issues and things of that sort
and we're still talking about the nature
of fates within the world as we seed
within the globalization processes but
we're slowly getting there I trust you
you see that so states of faith in the
world today that's today also but also
we are interested in the question of of
tomorrow what are some of them how do we
extrapolate from the from the from today
in regards to tomorrow we're interested
in particular in two things religious
adherence do faiths continue to claim
the hearts and minds of people around
the globe as much as they did in the
past will they do so in the future and
even if you have the numbers what do
these numbers mean what do they really
Express how do we interpret the numbers
that we receive in terms of religious
adherence second issue we're interested
in the public role of Fame our fates a
force that shapes realities beyond
people's private and mainly narrowly
communal lives if so will they do so
also in the future and if they will in
what ways will fades be a significant
force in the future I think we're also
interested in and that's the subject for
our discussion topic for our discussion
is the changing character of faiths how
is the character of faiths being shaped
and reshaped by globalization processes
given that changing character what
possibilities of influence on people
within globalization processes and what
possibilities of influence on
globalization
as themselves are there for faith so in
the word we'll trying to discern stand
learn something more about that world of
faith let me say a few words about faith
about globalization and its relationship
to secularization and the reason why we
are immediately bringing in
secularization because secularization
thesis seems to be today in academic
circles at least almost a default
position notwithstanding the fifty
almost 50 years of work that Professor
Martin has done when he originally
resisted that thesis it in in the 60s
but I think he's winning is winning the
day right it's clear that a
globalization is modernization right
it's fueled by modern economic
arrangements it's mediated by
technological advances advancement
specially of communication it's assuming
and I think reinforcing a very modern
phenomenon of individual a shin you've
seen that especially in some of the
readings of Peter Berger that we had for
today and it's fashioning and
refashioning alternative global not
quite culture right there plurality of
culture but something like globe or
subculture substratum of global culture
now so some globalization is
modernization but is globalization
therefore secularization well if
modernization is secularization then
globalization will be secularization as
well but that's really the question is
modernization equal to secularization
does it entail decline of religion and
society decline of religion in the minds
of individuals if it does then obviously
globalization will lead to
secularization and if there are
religions do survive they survive as
because people hold on to the Past
caused by either unfinished character of
modernization processes we haven't
reached at the end of modernism
station when religion will disappear or
maybe by social inertia for a while and
if there may be resurgence of Lee
religion that resurgent will be only the
last gasp of religion before its final
demise that's if globalization equals
modernization equals secularization well
if modernization is not secularization
if there are also religious ways to be
modern and that's the pieces that we are
entertaining that we have been reading
about then embrace of secularism will be
just one way to modernize and embrace of
multiple fates maybe alternative ways to
modernize we'll look at that whole
question especially during our next
session when we contrast European model
with wide variety of other options that
are available to us so in that case
modernization if it's not secularization
globalization doesn't necessarily lead
to secularization and then the question
I think remains for us to ask for more
factual nature well how religious will
the 21st century be what fates will
thrive and where what forms will faith
stake in that 21st century now I've got
a whole bunch of stuff that I need to
explore here and we'll have to do it
relatively relatively quickly summing up
some of the issues I think that are
before us and that's under the rubric
globalization's impact on faith setting
up a stage for our discussion now I
think let me just enumerate relatively
quickly a few things first globalization
is shaping the overarching conditions
under which people embrace faith and one
can describe that name may be partially
at least as mal content with
globalization processes I left people
are left out of globalization benefits
people experience is injustice an
account of globalization processes
people are believing that globalization
process
undermine local cultures or people are
experiencing this orientation as a
result of globalization processes people
are sensing maybe meaninglessness of the
prevalent ends within globalization
processes or people are believing the
globalization processes when driven by
market forces undermine human
flourishing you can go down the list of
different reasons why people might then
in contrast finding themselves caught in
globalization processes choose to
embrace faith now that's globalization
shaping overarching conditions under
which people believe but the
globalization is shaping also the very
form which faith takes and there are a
number of things that we have found in
our reading one is something like
democratization of faiths which would
fit the anti hierarchical strand in
globalization processes themselves
selves or globalization might be
detaching fades from particular locales
and making them global faiths that's
connected maybe with this embedding
characteristics of globalization
processes maybe rediscovery almost
paradoxically of the cultural
specifically specific forms of faith
right there is this global faith but
incarnates itself in particular ways in
a given culture and then there's this
phenomenon of smorgasbord religiosity
right individually created faith
tailored to individual needs made from
well something like nuggets of religious
wisdom taken in an ad-hoc fashion from
whatever source is available and deemed
useful and maybe containing no
overarching interpretation of life and
with highly attenuated sense of Ultima
see religion is here merely useful and
not ultimate and often understood I
think that's probably important as a
matter of personal taste rather than as
a matter of truth claims
globalization is also that's undersea
shaping modes of transmission of faith
technology of delivery new Missionary
movements going from east to west
counter emissions is the term that has
been used for that Reeve and realizing
of the west by non Westerners missions
between non-western countries movement
is going every which direction it's
swirling and it's no longer from the
center to the periphery and finally
globalization may be shaping the modes
of religious influence globalization
shaping fades forms of engagement with
globalization processes themselves
certain forms of agency are made
possible by globalization processes you
know i'm thinking say of the
significance of figures representing a
large religious institution benedict the
sixteen or john paul the second he could
become john paul the second the world
leader because of globalization
processes or alternative modes of
influence like hores matic figures who
have available at their fingertips even
from a cave access to influence and
communicate with just about everybody on
the globe that becomes another way in
which religious faith is disseminated
and influence is created and then
finally in terms of that influence well
we need to talk about the scope of that
influence all spheres of life often
religious for religions thought of
themselves as being regularly all
spheres of life is that possible under
conditions of globalization processes
such questions and many alike we need to
explore your thoughts kali cooper was
coming down right well it is slowly come
on have patience it will come down for
now just hovering slightly above maybe
comfort zone of some of you
at any rate those are some of the
questions we will explore we have
explored and we will continue explore
and now I would like to welcome
professor David Martin to address us for
in particular I think emphasis will be
on what he has studied in a unique way
right he studied in unique way and that
is a question of worldwide
pentecostalism to introduce him I'm
reminded is Christie professor David
morning is a fellow of the British
Academy emeritus professor of sociology
at London School of Economics
international fellow at the Boston
University Institute of world of affairs
and sometime distinguished professor of
human values at Southern Methodist
University he is global he is a regular
contributor to The Times Literary
Supplement many of you may have read his
work there and author of some 20 books
his books and works are concerned with
processes of secularization religion and
politics especially the role of religion
in issues of peace and war violence and
the worldwide surgery Pentecostalism and
he will be having from what I understand
a forthcoming times literary supplement
article on just out oh okay this week
obviously I haven't read that yet which
has some impact on our presidential
election and one of the vice
presidential candidates so Professor
Martin thank you very much well it's a
great privilege to be here and thank
thank you for inviting me the helicopter
is going to hover and at a slight angle
to what you were saying but I think it
can be pulled back into the set of
issues that you were that you outlined
just now like all of us my background
actually shaped my intellectual
interests there there has been a long
history of exchange of religious capital
between the England and
and America and my grandparents and my
father were both swept him to a current
of American revivalism and so I was set
certain basic questions there's nothing
like a fundamentalist background for
having think hard so and also about
peace and violence because that raised
for me the question of the authority of
the New Testament with regard to peace
and war so that that's why and also it
may be intensely interested in the issue
of secularization because if all my
sociological colleagues thought that
religion was on the way out then my
parents had made a rather serious
mistake so I had really to examine two
things the question of religion in
relation to politics and violence and
what it on the way out those those that
was the agenda that my background set me
regarding the first that is to say
pacifism peace and and violence um I
concluded that there was a strong
relation between taking a piece witness
and the expectation of the kingdom of
God and that i'm not going to develop
now but i concluded there was a very
strong relationship between the two
kinds of refusing to fight and expecting
the world to be remade in the in the
image of the kingdom of god but what
about sakuras ation secularization was
perhaps more complicated i concluded 43
years ago that second ization was both a
prescription and a description the
prescription was either ideologically
inflicted above all by western ration
ism basically the notion almost the s
catechol eschatological notion
that reason would be triumphant and you
would move from the realm of religious
darkness to the realm of rational light
so you see there's already a religious
element in the in the rationalist
expectation it took over the Christian
imagery of light insofar as it was
prescriptive it involved the notion that
one day the whole the earth would be
like either France or Sweden and the
contemporary formulation of that is
called Europe that American is called
American exceptionalism that is that if
all the world one day would be like
France or Sweden then America was
somehow the odd one out and so on had to
explain just why America was somehow
missed out on me on the universal road
to progress the other version was that
it was the other way around which is
Peter burgers version and that's to say
that places like France and Sweden are
kind of sports in the in the progress of
history that America's sort of natural
and normal and the old one out is Europe
and so that's called European
exceptionalism and sociology in this
area moves backwards and forwards
between thinking the fundamental thing
is that America's exception on the other
is that Europe is the exceptional one
okay once that argument was complete I
decided that I was try and write a more
modest general theory of synchronization
which was descriptive from prescription
to description basically that was
formulated nearly 40 years ago and it
called itself rather grandiose giaghran
general theory of secularization and it
was quite simple start point one
functional differentiation that is the
separation of autonomous spheres of
human activity like education and
welfare from ecclesiastical control and
the theological modality but above all
the separation of church and state that
that's a major form of functional
differentiation because that frees
religions on the habla queen of
political power and social status been
associated with the elite but it also
allows lydon to return as the spirit of
the nation that is to say as patriotism
point to a lot depends here on the
positive or negative relationship of
religion to the national myth as you
know in the United States it's very
positively related to the national myth
democracy religion and America all go
together god Bless America on the other
and that's also true in certain other
situations for example in Ireland and
Poland where british imperialism and
russian imperialism meant an
identification of the nation with
catholicism a positive relation negative
relations are france which emerged in a
contest between catholicism and the
spirit of reason or the czech republic
and can and now east germany point three
a lot depends and this is more
complicated on whether religion is
Protestant angelical with a strong sense
of the individual and individual choice
or catholic with a strong sense of the
community and of territory and the
indeed a relationship to power power
a community and territory and I suppose
one might slip in Islam here as and as
another case alongside Catholicism as
having that particular group of
characteristics now whether Catholicism
or Protestant evangelicalism aligns
itself on the left or the right depends
where it is socially situated for
example in Britain where Catholicism
with a minority it moved to the largely
supported the Labour Party the same in
Australia where the same conditions
obtained and to some extent I think also
true in the United States where there
has been in the past day of tradition of
democratic voting by the by Catholics
now evangelicalism by virtue of this
emphasis on choice and the
disentanglement from territory is
implicitly pluralistic and lay it goes
back of course to the priesthood of all
believers and this has been achieved its
major realization in the united states
where it flourishes on competition so
this these if you like our individual
people choosing this is this is the
model anyway choosing on a religious
market and doing so in terms of as free
autonomous individuals now catholicism
has often been in the past monopolistic
it hasn't welcomed competition and
that's given rise to radical
anti-clericalism so whereas
evangelicalism often can go alongside
with go along with democratization in
certain contexts catholicism at
particular stage in its development that
we
careful resisted that the breakup of its
monopoly and produced very strong
counter movements especially in in
Europe now what is the what is the
trajectory of evangelical pluralism it
began initially inside the church in
Germany it then broke outside the church
in Britain and it became fully
pluralistic in the United States my
argument is that it was finally realized
in a decentralized fissionable form in
pentecostalism a faith which was
dislocated from territory not connected
with political power indeed often a
political and totally decentralized
decentralized lay based on choice
separated from territory and from power
and in that sense highly adapted to the
modern global situation so we have
actually arrived at globalization at
last okay
choice and choice versus birthright
voluntary Association versus territorial
monopoly remember that most in most
European countries eight percent of the
population notionally belongs to a
particular a one particular church so
there's the third and rather complicated
element of the theory the fourth element
has to do with empirical correlations
which I won't bother you with such as
the best the bigger the city the the
smaller the degree of religious
participation the more heavy industry
the smaller the degree of religious
participation and the universal gender
difference which by the way is very
important okay so that those were the
elements in the in the theory okay
function differ asian differentiation
the relationship to the national myth
the whether it was this the particular
form thats related to plaza
evangelicalism or relation to
catholicism and then finally the various
empirical correlations which could all
be worked through these historical
variations here ed what about
pentecostalism pentecostalism has now
displaced Eastern Orthodoxy as the
second largest sector of Christianity
and it is it runs parallel with I have
written down here it is arrival with an
islamic revivalism its origins go back
to methodism especially the holiness
tradition and if you look at my time to
do something article it it spells all
this out and two movements which realize
the free availability of spiritual gifts
to all gifts to all as it broke out in
los angeles in 1906 with William samora
black preacher there were scenes of
interracial interracial enthusiasm
and it combined white and black
revivalism what does that mean it meant
that it was pre adapted to spread in the
third world in a way that wasn't really
available to mainstream Christianity
mainstream Christianity seemed to be
something partially alien but
pentecostalism because it already had
these these elements in it was pre
adapted to that to the developing world
and so all those other elements that
I've mentioned about decentralization d
territorial ization all those other
things were combined with this further
element that this further elements of
pre adaptation pluralistic fissile
disconnected from territory pre adapted
and that helped it to spread in a
transnational multi cultural society and
we're nice Methodism had mobilized the
masses in the industrial revolution as
they made their way to the industrial
city so Pentecostalism mobilizes the
masses on a global scale on their way to
the global mail mega city it's
interesting that of the two possible
women that might have become president
the united states one hillary clinton
was a Methodist okay so she was at that
stage and the other sarah palin is a
Pentecostal so my little sequence is
actually parallel paralleled by Hillary
Clinton and Sarah Sarah Palin now to
whom does Pentecostalism appeal it
appeals to buried people's marginalized
whole peoples which is surprising if
it's not territorial but it does manage
to do that in the Andes and it appeals
to European
see for example one it appeals to women
why because it reforms men and brings
them back into a disciplined monogamous
family it also appeals to what I call a
buried intended tell agencia that is too
highly energetic intelligent men who
don't who would actually be filtered
through the edge of the normal
educational system but in fact become
religious captains of industry it's it
is not true that all the intelligent
people in the world go through
universities and get PhDs as we
discussed over lunch in fact there are
other avenues in which people as it were
work out their personal salvation and
this is a remarkable set of men that run
these religious that are religious
captains of industry they set up as
religious entrepreneurs and they run
organizations that are autonomous social
capital based on no alcohol no drugs no
smoking no women at the weekend no going
from one family to another and leaving
allelic leaving the children with one
woman after another and of course this
is one reason why it appeals to women
because if you go to a Pentecostal
church and these are the standards these
the criteria membership this means that
the state of stability of their family
which is essential to women is is secure
so I have actually been called their
Pentecostalism the global trade global
women's trade union people have said to
me can you really prove that you get
social mobility through Pentecostalism
and I simply say
if you give up drugs alcohol women and
then you engage in hard work and and
have a discipline family life that those
things automatically you don't need
further evidence you can work it out for
yourselves that but also in the in the
Pentecostal churches you have an
autonomous form of social capital that
provides you with training to get on so
you're not run in simply running your
own organization you're also building in
business schools or in in the in Nigeria
you'd be building in perhaps a community
bank so it's of all embracing
environment finally how am I for time by
the way where's my five minutes a man
I've got ah alright so how does it
relate to the religious right in the US
and what about near but New
Pentecostalism it's just just about
right I don't claim to be an expert on
the religious right in the US but I
think it's a pity if Pentecostalism is
just assimilated to fundamentalism the
important element is the available
availability of spiritual gifts to
everybody now evangelicalism and
pentecostalism both have mixed political
records and this is characteristic of
all religions because the political
stances that religions take depend on
how where they are socially located not
straightforwardly on the religious
repertoire but how their social location
encourages them to pick particular parts
of their religious repertoire for use in
particular situations
so evangelicalism itself is bound to be
politically ambiguous moving between
this position and that position all the
same it was historically associated with
them anti-slavery and black
evangelicalism was associated with the
civil rights movement now it seems to me
that in the the 60s convulsions moral
convulsions psychological convulsions
brought out a long-term strain in
evangelicalism and Pentecost them
worrying about moral deterioration that
there was a shift to more explicitly
towards the right and one of the
elements in and this was what is it to
be womanly what is it to be manly if I
do use the word manly and my my thesis
is that someday like Sarah Palin
actually feel fits into people who want
to ask that particular question at the
same time there's being a move within
evangelicalism which is out of this kind
of political ghetto a broader
perspective emerging and evangelical
intelligentsia as well as the telly
evangelist remember that both obama and
palin have strong evangelical roots and
they both have passed to trouble so
finally yes global neo Pentecostalism
Leo Pentecostalism now the Americans
have never been ashamed of prosperity so
it's not surprising that you could have
a health and wealth gospel where
prosperity is a sign of being blessed at
the same time the African and I would
say the Latin American religious
imagination relate the goods to the gods
not only that if you read the Hebrew
Scriptures which these people do avidly
they find there's an upbeat version
which says you know that the poor that
sorry that the righteous will not want
for bread the righteous shall not want
for bread so I've daringly called this
movement afro Jewish and what does it do
it combines two things on the one hand
at the level of the megachurch and now
i'm not talking about all the hundreds
of little churches that honeycomb the
downtown areas of cities all over the
world I'm now talking about the mega
churches what does it do it combines the
organization of the corporation plus the
provision of autonomous social capital
for the masses and it is almost anywhere
and everywhere and it moves from south
to south and north to south and south to
north exactly in the way that was was
was explained earlier so that you have
the center of Kiev the Embassy of God
have founded by a nigerian who went to
Russia to learn Marxism and ended up by
founding a mega church in EF if that's
not globalization I don't know what at
what is so on the one hand the small
churches of the little people that
honeycomb poor areas all over the world
and on the other hand these mega
churches autonomous social capital
empowerment and especially empowerment
for women thank you very much